le tornado depuis son vol inaugural il y
à plus de 25 ans le pana via tornado est
devenu l'un des plus importants avions
de combat au monde
avec des commandes portant sur plus d'un
millier d'avions une forme l'ossature de
trois grandes forces aériennes est
devenu l'avion de combat le plus courant
en europe de l'ouest
en plus de 15 ans de service
opérationnel il a fait taire les
critiques et a prouvé qu'il était un
formidable avions de combat d'attac
polyvalent
aussi à l'aise dans les missions de
reconnaissance d'interception que deux
frappes tactique il est le plus rapide
des avions au monde
au niveau de la mer est l'un des plus
performants à n'importe quel autre
altitude
à près de 1000 km heure il peut voler à
la hauteur des arbres par tous les temps
et larguer ses armes avec une précision
stupéfiante
plus de cinq tonnes de bombes peuvent
être accrochées sous le fuselage
laissant ainsi les ailes libre pour
remporter des réservoirs largable des
missiles ou des contre mesures
dans l'émission d' attaque à long rayon
d'action à basse altitude et un
supersonique les haines à géométrie
variable du tornado font merveille
la véritable histoire du tornado
commence en 1967 lorsque les armées de
l'air allemande italienne belge et
hollandaise ont commencé à étudier la
possibilité de produire conjointement un
avion qui pourrait remplacer leurs
lockheed f 104 starfighter victime de
nombreux accidents capable d'emporter
des missiles et quelques bombes le
starfighter un avion très rapide était
utilisé pour de nombreuses missions dont
la tacc à basse altitude l'entraînement
l'interception et la reconnaissance
son remplaçant devrait donc accomplir
toutes ses missions et remplir les
besoins spécifiques de chaque pays
l'étude s'annonçait donc plein de
problèmes insurmontables
cette même année l'angleterre et le
canada rejoignirent le groupe et la
complexité du programme augmente a
encore
alors que les accords généraux
s'accordait autour d'un chasseur
bombardier polyvalent chaque pays
exigeait un avion avec des niveaux de
performance différents et des armements
particulier les discussions continuaient
mais de nombreux points restent en
suspens pendant plus d'un an la belgique
et le canada se retirèrent alors du
consortium en mars 1969 les quatre
nations restantes
forner pana via une compagnie
internationale dont l'objet était de
mener le projet à son terme
en juillet la hollande suivi l'exemple
de la belgique et du canada et se retira
également laissant l'allemagne l'italie
et la grande bretagne comme seul
actionnaire
trois grandes entreprises aéronautiques
entrée au capital de panat via
l'allemand mbb et l'anglais british
aerospace disposant chacun de 42 5% et
l'italien haéri talia possédant les 15%
du capital restants si le projet
aboutissait il aurait le potentiel pour
un grand nombre de contrats dont pour
réduire les coûts et augmenter la
rentabilité
une seconde compagnie fut formé pour le
développement des moteurs en septembre
1969 turbo union fut formé la société
était constituée par trois motoristes
différents rolls royce en angleterre
fiat en italie et l'allemand mt eu
un accord détaillant les spécifications
du futur avion avait été signé elle
avait désigné m
rca pour multi role combat aircraft basé
dans ses nouveaux locaux à bristol turbo
union
comment ça le développement du r&b 199
impuissant petit réacteur étudié par
rolls royce
en ce qui concerne le fuselage
la décision avait été prise assez tôt
que le mrc a serait construit en deux
versions une monoplace et une biplace
les quatre principaux clients seraient
la rhf l'aviation italienne la luftwaffe
et l'aviation de la marine allemande la
marine flieger bien qu'il y ait parfois
d'importantes différences dans les
exigences de chaque arme
le mrc à se devait de remplir ses
missions avec la même excellence la rfa
chercher un biplace d'attac capable de
missions d'interdiction à basse altitude
contre des aérodromes ou des
concentrations de chars de véhicules
blindés et de troupes ennemies la
luftwaffe et l'aéronautique a military
italiano chercher toutes deux un
chasseur monoplace polyvalent tandis que
la marine flieger avait besoin d'un
avion antinavires
pas ma vie a décidé d'employer une aile
à géométrie variable ce qui permettait
de conserver à l'appareil une taille
raisonnable tout en étant capable
d'excellentes performances en hausse
comme en basse vitesse et en altitude
combiné avec 2 rbds et 199 l'est la
géométrie variable permettait aux mrc à
standard d'assurer chaque pays d'obtenir
précisément de l'avion qu'il recherchait
les exigences de la rs pour un avion
tout temps signifiait que le nouvel
appareil aurait besoin d'emporter de
nombreux systèmes d'avionique
sophistiqués ceci entraînant le choix
d'un équipage de deux hommes un pour
piloter l'avion et un second pour gérer
les systèmes électroniques
après avoir repenser leurs procédures
les allemands et les italiens
aubeterre également pour la version
biplace au lieu de leurs préférences
initial pour un monoplace les plans d'un
mrc à monocle assure donc abandonné au
début de 1970 laissant la version
biplace seul en développement vers la
fin de cette année là les ventes
potentielles s'élevait à environ 900
exemplaires
400 étaient destinés à la rhf 300 pour
l'aviation allemande et une centaine
pour l'aviation italienne et autant pour
la marine allemande alors que pana via
travaillait sur le prototype et que
turbo unyon testait le r&b 199 d'autres
grandes sociétés furent engagés pour
fournir les systèmes embarqués
texas instruments et obtint le contrat
pour le radar et ferranti pour le
système de navigation inertielle en
dépit de l'opposition constante de la
presse et des politiciens
le prototype fut terminée à la fin de
1973 après l'assemblage final l usine
mbb d'ottobrunn il commence à ces essais
moteurs au début de 1974 vers l'été ils
étaient prêts à s'envoler dans l'après
midi du 14 août il décollé de
l'aérodrome de man ching le vol
inaugural durera un peu plus de trente
minutes et ne révéla pas de problèmes
sérieux sur le fuselage ou les moteurs
le 30 octobre le premier prototype a
semblé en angleterre fit son premier vol
à partir de wharton l'équipage était
constitué de paul millet de b à c et
niels master 2ème et b ont les marées
les moteurs tout était absolument
normale
on l'a testé les commandes de vol les
gouvernent les volets et les systèmes
hydrauliques
tout était ok
descendu le taxiway puis on s'est
alignée sur la piste on a laisser
décoller deux avions d'escort
j'ai relâcher les freins l'avion
accélérer franchement et progressivement
au moment où on a passé 120 nu j'ai
relâché la pression sur le manche et
l'avion a décollé pour la première fois
avec 169 en vitesse de montée
ils veulent est comme nous l'espérions
j'ai laissé les volets sortis à 10
degrés pour monter jusqu'à dix mille
pieds là nous avons fait les essais à 2
100 de s'envoler
il se manie encore mieux que prévu voilà
donc accéléré jusqu'à 300 2 pour tester
sa maniabilité qui s'est révélé
absolument parfaite
on est ensuite descendu pour revenir
vers l'aérodrome
c'est un passage à 300 pieds on est
passés vente arrière et j'ai ralenti
l'avion pour le mettre en configuration
d' approche volet est ressorti que tu es
bien sorti comme prévu et le
comportement de l'avion à basse altitude
est en approche
il était aussi bon que ce que nous
avions constaté pendant les tests en
haute altitude
en finale il était totalement stable
donc j'ai fait une approche et j'ai
remis les gaz
je suis revenu pour enfin atterrir le
monsieur le comportement de l'avion
était toujours parfait stable que les
sans problème mais départ c'était comme
si c'est avion volé depuis de nombreuses
années il était vraiment sympa à piloter
je fus un vol d'essai absolument parfait
le 30 octobre le premier prototype a
semblé en angleterre fit son premier vol
à partir de wharton
en 1976 cette machine supplémentaire
avait volé portant le total des
prototypes à 9
la même année le mrc a fut
officiellement baptisé tornado et de là
à la fin de la décennie
ces autres avions avaient rejoint le
programme d'essai lorsqu'il fut prêt à
entrer en service en juillet 1981 le
projet en ado avait pris 13 ans pour
aboutir avec pas loin de 5000 heures
d'essai en vol il était l'un des plus
longs programmes de développement jamais
effectuée pour un avion militaire alors
que le mrc a était un programme
multinational
les trois nations avaient choisi de
former leurs équipages au sein d'une
seule école de pilotage spéciale les
premiers tornado entrèrent en service
lorsque deux avions furent livrés au tri
national tornado training établissment
sur la base de la rs est mort en
angleterre le premier groupe
d'instructeurs étaient eux-mêmes
entraînée par les pilotes d'essai de
panat via
il employait une nouvelle approche pour
l'entraînement des équipages les
personnels qui étaient issus de chaque
pays et est intégré un binôme pilote
navigateur quelle que soit leur
nationalité d'origine
ceux-ci s'avéra une excellente méthode
de conversion d'équipage et le ttt eux
permis ainsi d'introduire un haut degré
de coopération entre les différentes
aviations de l'otan les avantages
d'avoir un centre d'entraînement
multinationales et d'abord son côté
social
parce qu'il faut le meilleur de chaque
pays l'allemand le vin italien et tous
les produits de chaque pays
sur le plan professionnel je pense que
beaucoup de gens s'inquiétaient de
savoir si cela allait marcher ou pas en
fait on l'a prouvé que ça marche très
très bien quand les équipages arrive ici
on se débrouille pour les mélanger à
d'autres nationalités pilote et un
navigateur anglais arrive on s'assure
qu'ils ne feront pas équipage ensemble
mais avec d'autres pilotes ou
navigateurs on y gagne beaucoup par
exemple les pilotes anglais ont
l'habitude de voler très bas
ça permet d'entraîner les pilotes qui
eux n'ont jamais volé dans la région
aussi car l'unité est au coeur du
différend tactique et on peut ainsi
apprécier les méthodes qu'ils
utiliseront plus tard dans leur carrière
alors que l'école c'est au fait
progressivement les avions étaient
fournis par chaque pays pour former une
flotte d'entraînement de 50 machines
après avoir appris à voler sur leur
nouvel avion les équipages de la rff
était entraîné à combattre aux tornades
aux iphone ce commercial unit de
huntington formé en juin 1981 il
commença à prendre livraison de ses
premiers avions en août de la même année
cinq mois plus tard le 6 janvier 1982 le
squadron 9 devant la première unité
opérationnelle des trois pays à recevoir
le tornado au sein de la r f
la version d'attaqué d'interdiction
dénommé idée s était désigné tornado gr4
que l'angleterre avait programmé une
version d'interception à long rayon
d'action
il fallut près de trois années
supplémentaires avant que la version à
des v pour air des femmes'' variante tu
prêtes à entrer en service
la production des versions wii ds
augmentant le marine figurent allemand
reçu ses premières livraisons juillet
1982 en octobre le squadron 617 les
fameux briseur de barrage devint la
seconde unité sur gr 1 à devenir
pleinement opérationnelles au sein du
strike command de la rff en août 1983
le tornado avait intégré les unités de
la luftwaffe et de l'aviation italienne
est le premier des six escadrons de la
rs basé en allemagne avait commencé son
équipement avec des gr 1 une importante
charge utile et d'excellentes
performances à basse altitude font du gr
un avion d'attaqué idéal pour les
opérations en profondeur sur le théâtre
européen
les 2 rbds et 199 développant plus de
7000 tonnes à pleine charge chacun lui
donne une vitesse maximum de maths 2,2 à
36 mis les pieds la vitesse maximum au
niveau de la mer et de mac 1,2 et les
systèmes avancés permettent aux pilotes
de rester supersonique tout en volant
entre 100 et 200 pieds à pleine charge
l'avion a une masse limite de 30 mille
kilos environ lui permettant d'emporter
une charge militaire de 4000 kg
avec tout son armement le gr 1 un rayon
d'action de 1500 km
son armement interne est constitué de
deux canons mother de 27 mm montés bas
sous le fuselage de chaque côté du train
avant
une grande variété d'armes de réservoir
et d'équipement de contre mesures
peuvent être remportés sous le fuselage
et les quatre pylônes ou dell chaque
pylône d'elles est conçu pour pivoter
afin de maintenir larmes qui n'emporte
dans laxe de l'avion quel que soit
l'angle de la flèche de l'ale bien que
les trois forces aériennes européennes
employons le tornado ont leur
configuration d'armement de prédilection
la rff la amy et la luftwaffe font
confiance aux sags winder comme missiles
de défense standard pour le tornado
l'armement offensif du tornado dans la r
f peut varier considérablement des
banques conventionnelles aux armes
nucléaires
il est capable d'emporter une bombe
nucléaire de 500 kilos tonnes ou bien
huit bombes de 454 kg conventionnelle ou
guidées laser paix vous est contrôlé par
le système d'acquisition de cible lr mts
monter dans le nez de l'avion
la bombe p vous est peut-être lancé par
un avion est guidé par un autre utilisé
contre des cibles statique comme des
ponts des hangars en force et des postes
de commandement ou d'installations
pétrolifères ces bombes peuvent être
d'une précision démoniaque des bombes
guidées laser ont une efficacité
supérieure à 80%
ça marche parce que vous pouvez disposer
d'un autre avion qui pointe son rayon
laser sur la cible à l'avant de ce qui
n'était qu'une bête bon classique il ya
un capteur laser
c'est quand la bombe est lâchée le
capteur repères l'énergie du laser
renvoyé par la cible ça signifie que
vous avez 90 % de chances de toucher la
cible est qu une seule bombe guidée
laser peut faire plus de dégâts qu'une
salve de bons non guidés ça veut dire
aussi qu'un seul avion avec deux bombes
guidées laser fera plus de dégâts que
six ou sept avions équipés de bombes
lice traditionnels
deux armes sont venus s'ajouter à
l'arsenal des tornado le missile alarme
qui est utilisé contre les radars de
défense aérienne et la jp 233 bombes à
sous munitions pour saturer les
aérodromes et demi deux énormes
conteneurs sont montés sous le fuselage
qui peuvent être chargés de 250
sous-munitions explosives
cette charge est constitué de bombes
âgées 357 destinée à détruire la piste
et de mines hb 876 qui descendent sous
un parachute conçu pour endommager les
pistes et empêcher les réparations
une entre armes à sous-munitions et
l'abbé l755 qui contient environ 150
petites bombes anti tank
l'aviation allemande est également
équipé de bl 755 mais elle dispose de
son propre système entier aérodrome
le mv 1 une fois encore la section plate
sous le fuselage permet à montage idéal
pour de telles armes volumineuse à
pleine charge les conteneurs qui mesure
cinq mètres peuvent embarquer jusqu'à
cinq tonnes et lancé une quantité
phénoménale et dévastatrice de munitions
sur des surfaces variable plusieurs
centaines de sous-munitions peuvent être
emportés simultanément il peut s'agir de
minou d'armes anti blindage pour
détruire des chars et d'autres véhicules
renforcer ou de bombes à fragmentation
pour attaquer les troupes ennemies les
armes standards de la luftwaffe sont les
bombes explosives de 200 500 et 1000
livres pour l'émission antinavires les
tornado de l'aviation navale allemande
sont armés de bombes conventionnelles de
250 à 1000 livres mais leur arme
principale et le missile aéroportée
antinavire cormorans
généralement emporté par paire ces
missiles ont une portée d'environ 30
kilomètres et peuvent voler juste au
dessus de la surface de la mer à une
vitesse d'environ 1000 km heure les
informations sur la cible sont fournis
initialement par l'ordinateur de l'avion
mais une fois lancé le système de
navigation embarqués et le système radar
permettent aux cormorans de trouver de
toucher sa cible seul avec une très
grande précision
alors qu'il est l'équipement standard du
marines rigueur le cormoran est
également utilisé par l'aviation
italienne dans les tornado effectué de
nombreux types de missions différent de
l'attak antinavire à l' attaque au sol
les autres armes employées comprennent
le conteneur allemand mv 1 et la bombes
à dispersion bl 755 depuis son entrée en
service avec la rfa en 1982 le temps
nadeau a régulièrement prouvé son
efficacité en prenant part à un grand
nombre d'exercices internationaux
le premier a eu lieu en 1984 lorsqu'un
groupe d'avions du squadron 617 fut
engagée au cours de bombardements
organisé par le strategic air command de
lui à ses forces lui douzaine d'équipés
engagées représentaient des forces
aériennes de toute la planète
équipée avec quelques-uns des avions de
combat les plus modernes jamais
construit elle est l élite des équipages
de bombardements de chaque armée les
tornado de la rfm réussir des scores
quasi parfait pour obtenir les première
et seconde place des concours
individuels par avion la deuxième place
de la compétition par paire est la
première et la troisième place dans un
duel contre les f111 de l'us airforce
comparer le tornado à d'autres avions
semble plus facile que sean l'est
réellement
par rapport aux récents jeux tornado et
plus léger en fait l'avion qui se
rapproche le plus du f111 aurait été le
tsr2 s'il avait été mis en service ce
sont des avions d'une même génération
le temps à nous ressembler songeons mais
c'est la moins d'autonomie es11 a été
conçu pour un rôle de bombardiers
stratégiques
les premières sont j'avais un système de
navigation assez rudimentaire mais les
différentes évolutions qu'il a connus
font que ses capacités actuelles sont
similaires à celles du temps ados
d'aujourd'hui le s en est un avion plus
grands conçues avec une plus grande
autonomie comparable à celle du tsr2 ou
bien le vulcan à l'époque
avec de tels résultats dans ces deux
premières compétitions le tornado se
taillait une formidable réputation à
l'échelle mondiale dans les années qui
suivirent les tornado de la rfm ont pris
part à des exercices opérationnels de
façon régulière
ceci comprend des exercices de combat
complexe et intensif comme les exercices
flag qui se tiennent aux usa et qui
permettent d'entraîner les équipages aux
missions de guerre au sein de force
multinationale green flag et red flag
sont organisées par l'us air force
depuis plus de 25 ans et font partie du
programme d'entraînement des équipages
de tornado j'ai participé à l'aller
premier red flag sur tornado en 1986
alors que j'étais basé en allemagne
cette époque l'intérêt de red flag
c'était d'être aussi proche que possible
une véritable guerre contre le pacte de
varsovie qui existaient encore à
l'époque c'était presque pour de vrai la
grande idée de red flag c'était
d'utiliser vraiment du matériel russe et
en faisant de bons scénarios avec une
météo toujours clément de guava
puisqu'on était dans le nevada l'idée
consistait à former des groupes pour
pénétrer dans la zone
vous l'avez des avions des puits et même
nos propres chasseurs d'escorté aussi
des avions agresseurs en fait c'était
des avions américains qui jouait les
russes en utilisant les tactiques russes
pour essayer de nous descendre tout
c'était de se retrouver dans des
conditions
les plus proches d'une véritable guerre
sans avoir de chance d'être helmand
descendu les équipages sont souvent
mobilisés dans des exercices au dessus
de l'allemagne de l'ouest en
coordination avec les autres armes ils
planifient des tests afin d'évaluer les
tactiques des équipages et la vitesse de
réaction du groupe
la première phase et les repérages sur
cartes et la préparation du programme
on est allé puis sur la table
électronique
le navigateur prépare son vol il croise
ces données avec les autres données
indispensables
le système produit ainsi un programme
très précis très détaillé qui sera
ensuite introduit dans l'ordinateur même
du temps à dos
sur un match durant le check list le
navigateur introduit donc la cassette
dans l'ordinateur de l'appareil
les données s'inscriront sur les deux
écrans à l'arrière du cockpit c'est le
plan de la mission sur ses écrans
s'inscriront tous les détails et les
données de la mission et de ses
objectifs
à l'intérieur de chaque cockpit un écran
pour cartes des roulants permettent aux
pilotes comme un navigateur d'avoir une
vue de leur trajectoire et de leurs
positions précises lors d'une mission de
bombardement les informations du radar
d'attac peuvent être combinés avec la
carte déroulante pour que les cibles
apparaît sur l'écran du navigateur
après avoir désigné électroniquement les
cibles sur l'écran le navigateur prend
le contrôle de l'avion par
l'intermédiaire de l'ordinateur à partir
de là l'ordinateur d'élise l'avion vers
le point d'attaquer lâchent les bombes
totalement automatiquement une fois
arrivé en position ce système
impressionnant permet d'effectuer des
missions d'attac avec la même précision
de jour comme de nuit par tous les temps
le radar de suivi de terrain du tornado
et le plus grand des deux systèmes
montés dans le nez avec l'itinéraire pré
programmés dans l'ordinateur de
navigation le radar peut prendre en
charge le pilotage automatique de
l'avion à une altitude de 200 pieds sans
que le pilote ne touchez commandes
le système est conçu pour voler à basse
altitude et par mauvais temps ou de nuit
en fait l'avion a été utilisé au combat
à basse altitude et de nuit le système
de navigation a été conçu pour maintenir
l'appareil à 200 pieds au dessus du sol
sans références visuelles extérieur pour
cela il y un radar de suivi terrain qui
alimente le pilote automatique en mode
automatique ce pour maintenir l'altitude
de sécurité au dessus du sol et des
obstacles
le système de navigation et lui relié à
l'ordinateur principal qui est
programmer manuellement par le système
de navigation inertielle assez similaire
à celui d'un avion de ligne
ensuite un radar de cartographie
manipulé par le navigateur est utilisée
pour mettre à jour et corrigé le plan de
vol d'après les repères au sol
généralement c'est assez efficace
malheureusement aucun ordinateur n'est
assez intelligent pour savoir si la
correction et justesse à washington de
fixer car s'il ya une seule erreur c'est
le risque de collision avec le terrain
les commandes de vol électroniques sont
le système le plus sophistiqué de
contrôle et de stabilisation utilisés
sur les avions de combat les plus
modernes
au coeur du csa s il y a deux
ordinateurs un pour le tangage 1 pour le
roulis et le lacet demain le pilote
donne ses ordres par l'intermédiaire du
manche et du palonnier ces informations
sont transmises ordinateur et elles sont
combinées avec les informations relayées
par les gyroscopes de tangage roulis est
là c'est pour autoriser les mouvements
des surfaces de contrôler les mouvements
de la gouverne de direction sont
ordonnés par l'ordinateur de lasser les
mouvements parallèles des surfaces
horizontales par l'ordinateur de tangage
de pelé mouvement différentiel comme
viennent des deux ordinateurs au grand
angle la sortie des spoilers et commandé
par l'ordinateur de roulis mais comme
plume tous cet ordinateur prend
également en compte la sortie des volets
et des aérofreins pour compenser les
couples qu'ils engendrent le css donne
ses ordres au système hydraulique
sillage ont subi des dommages au combat
que le système électrique et neutraliser
un système mécanique prend le relais
mais pour maintenir le contrôle de
l'appareil grâce css les goûts version
très homogène pour ce faire quelle que
soit la flèche de l'ale sur avion lice
au bout comme sur avion lourdement
chargé
le csa est réduit également la
sensibilité de l'avion rafale le
turbulent ce qui combiné à une forte
charge à l'air permet d'atteindre de
très haute vitesse ce qui réduit
d'autant le temps d'exposition aux
radars et aux tirs ennemis
la mission principale du tornado et de
voler à très basse altitude à ce niveau
là les turbulences peuvent être
terriblement sévère le système fly by
wire permet de piloter sans effectuer de
correction l'avantagé de ces systèmes
est d'offrir des conditions de vol plus
agréable sur n'importe quel autre avion
on se fait chahuter en très basse
altitude à la limite sur tornado
on pourrait avoir à bord une tasse de
café et la boire tranquillement sans
risquer de la renverser
malgré les turbulences les vols sont
moins fatiguant et permettent de mieux
se concentrer sur la mission proprement
dit si tu veux les en très basse
altitude sur un autre avion ne permet
pas non plus de voler aux instruments
ce car on ne peut pas les lire tellement
ça vibre l'esprit de collaboration qui a
uni si fortement les industriels et les
gouvernements avec nos partenaires
italiens et allemands et qu'une évidence
jamais bougé ceci ne doit pas être
masqué sauf que par notre fierté d'avoir
rendu ce tour nano f26 exceptionnel un
avion de combat avancé très puissante
intercepteurs équipés de missiles
moderne et d'un système de contrôle si
sophistiqué qui libère l'équipage du
pilotage tel est le tornado
je vous remercie donc tous et je vous
avoue mon plaisir et ma fierté d'être
ici pour vous dévoiler les deux premiers
temps nadeau à f2 c'est avec un grand
plaisir que j'inaugure la cérémonie
officielle
vers la fin de 1984 la version f2 de
défense aérienne entre est finalement en
service au sein de l'aef
les premières livraisons sur fait à
l'unité de conversion opérationnelle de
129 basé à koningshooikt dans le
lincolnshire puisqu'il est conçu pour
opérer dans un tout autre rôle que la
version ds le tornado de défense
aérienne comporte plusieurs
modifications majeures comme chasseur à
long rayon d'action il est équipé d'un
radar d'interception marconi fox hunter
à la place du système de suivi de
terrain ferranti utilisé en combinaison
avec les missiles air air sky flash le
système marconi a une capacité de
détection et de tire vers le bas pour
contrer une menace aérienne jusqu'à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres alors qu'un
mais a grandi permet d'y installer le
radar les réservoirs supplémentaires
permettent aux f2 d'emporter plus de
carburant que le tornado idée est ce
cela lui donne une autonomie de plus de
deux heures
il lui permet d'effectuer des
patrouilles aériennes de combat à plus
de 600 km de sa base
cette autonomie peut être largement
augmenté grâce au réservoir de carburant
supplémentaire largable et le
ravitaillement en vol avec un canon de
moins que sur la version idée s il y
assez de place pour que la perche de
ravitaillement en vol puis se rétracte
et entièrement à l'intérieur du côté
droit du fuselage
équipé du même réacteur marque 103 que
la version idéees le f2 n'était penser
que comme une solution provisoire en
attendant l'arrivée du f3 plus puissant
en avril 1987 le squadron 29 basé à
koningshooikt devint la première unité
formée sur tornado en f3 les
améliorations par rapport au f 2
comprenait des rails de lancement
supplémentaire pour 4,6 winder au lieu
de 2 et une commande automatique pour la
flèche des ailes pour le vol à basse
vitesse
les ailes sont placées selon un angle
relativement faibles afin d'augmenter la
surface et obtenir une plus grande porte
ans
la vitesse augmente et plus les elle
pivote vers l'arrière la position
maximum avec un angle d'environ 70
degrés est utilisé pour les vols à
grande vitesse là où il est nécessaire
d'avoir le minimum de traîner le pilote
peut manoeuvrer l'angle des ailes
manuellement avec à louviers à
l'intérieur du cockpit avec en
particulier les tuyères allongé pour
augmenter l'effet de la postcombustion
les réacteurs mk 104 améliorée du f3
augmente singulièrement la puissance
disponible
et
à pleine charge
le f3 pèse beaucoup moins que son cousin
idée s et avec une meilleure poussée à
toutes les altitudes
il accélère mieux et vole plus vite la
vitesse maximum à basse altitude et de
plus de 1400 kilomètres heure et à haute
altitude
elle est de plus de 2400 km heure alors
que la production du tornado à dv
suivait son cours à l'usiné de wharton
le f2 et f3 remplacer progressivement
les lightning et les fantômes de la rs
en 1997 si squadron du strike command
avait reçu le f3 la défense aérienne de
la grande bretagne était alors sous la
responsabilité du groupe 11 dont le
quartier général se trouve à bentley
priori dans le middlesex après avoir
pris la mission d'intercepteurs
principal au mc donnel douglas fantôme
le tornado en f3 continue de tenir ce
rôle
même après l'arrivée des premiers
eurofighter typhoon
alors opérationnelle avec les forces
aériennes anglaises allemandes et
italiennes
le tornado est aussi en service avec
deux autres nations en 1985 les
gouvernements de l'arabie saoudite et
oman ont annoncé une commande commune de
80 avions 32 de ces avions sont de la
version de défense aérienne et le reste
de la version d'attaqué d'interdiction
lorsque l'irak a envahi le koweït en
août 1990 les tornado d'arabie saoudite
ont rejoint ceux de la r f pour former
une partie de la force d' attaques de la
coalition internationale
l'engagement anglais dans ces opérations
étaient principalement le fait de la r f
sous le nom de code d'opérations granby
les escadrons de f3 et de gr 1
conjointement avec les jaguars ont
effectué leur mission à partir des bases
d'arabie saoudite et du bahreïn
le premier groupe de tornado était prêt
à entrer en action
moins de 24 heures après son arrivée
lorsque la coalition fut complète
deux cent cinquante mille hommes douze
mille véhicules de combat et 300 avions
été déployées dans la zone
aussi bien en quantité qu'en qualité
cette force aérienne était largement
supérieur à l'aviation irakienne et peu
après la puissance aérienne tactique
allait prouver son caractère décisif
les plans de la coalition pour son
offensive aérienne comportait quatre
phases
les deux premières concernaient la
destruction des systèmes de défense
aérienne irakien et le bombardement de
positions stratégiques clés tels que les
routes des ponts et les centres de
communication
la phase iii consistait à anéantir les
capacités de combat de l'armée irakienne
et la quatrième phase devait fournir
l'appui aérien nécessaires aux troupes
coalisées lors de la reconquête du
koweït
lorsque l'offensive aérienne commence à
le 16 janvier 1991
les premières missions des tornado
furent d'attaquer les aérodromes irakien
avec les bombes anti piste jp 233
menée de nuit ses missions à basse
altitude était d'une importance vitale
mais ce sont à merritt terriblement
dangereuse les tornado faire face à une
opposition féroce à la fois de la part
des canons antiaériens autant que de
missiles sam un avion fut abattu le
premier jour de la guerre et avant la
fin de la semaine
quatre autres avaient été perdus au
combat au début du conflit on a été
engagée pour des missions à très basse
altitude contre des objectifs très
lourdement défendu principalement des
aérodromes ou des dépôts ce qui nous a
causé un taux de perte assez important
par rapport aux autres participants au
conflit mais surtout peut-être considéré
malgré tout comme assez supportable si
on fait exception bien évidemment des
pertes humaines et en tenant compte du
fait que ces aérodromes étaient défendus
comme dr o drom soviétique
c'est à dire avec une flaque importante
et de nombreux missiles à guidage radar
ou infrarouge
ce n'était pas des missions facile
c'était le genre d'objectif pour sortir
l'egypte et 233 comme l'ont fait les
anglais et on s'expose beaucoup plus au
tiers et mis ensuite on a effectué des
missions à plus haute altitude ce qui
eut pour conséquence de réduire les
pertes sans toutefois les stopper
totalement ses pertes ont été
équivalentes à peu près à celle d'avions
plus moderne et plus légers comme le f16
pourtant capable de mieux manoeuvrer
pour se défendre en altitude en raison
de sa gestion énergétique mieux adaptée
alors que la coalition avait conquis la
suprématie aérienne les gr 1 furent
retirés de leur rôle d' attaque à basse
altitude pour le reste de la guerre ils
furent utilisés pour des missions à plus
haute altitude
en février la plupart des tornado avait
été engagé dans une campagne aérienne
contre les ponts irakien les routes et
les dépôts militaires au milieu du moins
les deux tiers des principaux ponts
avaient été détruits et la rfa avait
largué plus de deux mille bombes de 454
kg puis nous avons été engagés pour les
missions de tir en piqué grand-angle et
à haute vitesse et pour des tirs de
précision en utilisant généralement des
bombes à guidage laser on était capable
de toucher nos cibles avec beaucoup
d'efficacité parfois utilisé des bons
non guidées mais à moyenne altitude on
ne peut pas avoir la même précision à 12
cents pieds la précision est de l'ordre
de 100 pieds il faut donc des cibles
assez grande
par exemple il est impossible touchera
pont
l'aviation irakienne ayant été mise hors
de combat et donc incapable de disputer
la supériorité aérienne aux alliés et en
à doha dv n'avait que peu de chances
d'avoir l'opportunité d'engager des
combats aériens
la plupart des missions effectuées par
les f3 furent des patrouilles au dessus
du territoire irakien
la guerre s'acheva avant la fin du mois
de février mais dès que la coalition ont
gagné la supériorité aérienne
l'issue de la bataille était certaine à
la fin des hostilités un total de neuf
tornado avaient été détruits citant
nadeau gerin de la rfc un tornado idéees
de l'aviation italienne avaient été
perdus au combat tandis qu'un autre gr 1
et 1 idéees saoudiens avaient été
détruits dans des accidents sans rapport
avec les combats au total la coalition a
perdu 41 avions au cours de cette guerre
mais la destruction de 300 avions
irakien fut la démonstration de la
supériorité et de l'efficacité de la
technologie occidentale
c'est
depuis la guerre du golfe
les tornado de la rfa joué un rôle
crucial dans les efforts de paix de
l'onu dans l'ex yougoslavie
les détachements de f-35 squadron
différents comptes chacun pris le retour
au sein de la force aérienne
multinationales affectés à cette zone
pendant leurs six premiers mois de
service les tornado de la rfm ont
effectué plus de 500 missions comme
participation à l'opération de l'otan
dénis flight ils ont aidé à empêcher les
intrusions et ont permis de maintenir la
paix dans le ciel de bosnie
mon
non
vous
nous
on prend peur